The weekend is over.
We are now in 3.091.
So, announcement: this Wednesday
there will be no lecture,
instead, celebration of learning:
test number two.
These are the room assignments.
We moved them just a little bit,
moved the dividing lines, rather.
It's the same rooms,
but we wanted to make a little more
room in here and in the Walker gym.
So, there are more people being
asked to go to room 1-190.
And then, this is the group to go
to the Walker gym,
third floor of the Walker Memorial
building. And then,
the front half of the alphabet
please report here.
And, if you take the test that one
o'clock, don't go to 6-120 because
we won't be there.
We are putting everybody in 26-100.
That way there are plenty of
vacancies. So,
I'm just going to go quickly over
the comments that I give before
every test just to put everybody in
the right frame of mind.
The coverage is lecture 7-17.
So, that will start with ionics,
and go through the generation of
x-rays, but not Bragg's law or
anything like that.
So, remember, you've got to bring
five things with you: your periodic
table, table of constants,
something to write with, a
calculator, and your aid sheet.
And, you know,
I'm going to make a bold suggestion.
For some of you, why don't you
write your recitation instructor's
name on your aid sheet?
Because I'm going to tell you what
I'm going to do.
If I don't have a recitation
instructor's name on the exam,
I'm not going to grade it. You know
why? Because I've got 630 of these.
If you don't put the recitation
instructor's name on the exam,
it means you are in no hurry to get
it back.
That will save me time.
We'll just take all those,
and just put them aside, and we'll
just grade the ones for the people
who really want to get them back the
next day. And,
we'll get around to the other ones,
I mean, someday. So, I think after
two months, it's not unreasonable
for us to expect you to put the
recitation instructor's name on the
exam. The purpose of the test is to
provide you with feedback.
So, we want to just tell you,
are you mastering the material?
Are your study habits effective or
not? That's all we're trying to do.
So, this is not an aptitude test.
It's not an admissions test.
I just want to see if you're
mastering the material.
And if you are, I'm going to say
congratulations,
keep up the good work.
And if you're not, I'm going to
send you a message saying,
if you keep up at this level,
you're going to fail this class.
You need to get that information on
a timely basis.
What are the test taking strategies?
Read the paper first,
identify the easy questions,
work in your schedule, don't do
number one because I
made it number one.
Do number one only because it's the
easiest one for you.
It will be a confidence builder,
soothe the nerves, and so on. Show
your work. Show your work.
Don't write cryptic answers because
if you get them wrong,
we can't give you part score.
But, if you give us lots of
information, I don't mean volumes of
information, but if you give us a
few ideas as to how you are
approaching the problem,
then we can give you partial credit.
Work parametrically.
Try not to immediately start going
for your calculator.
And, please bring something to
compute with. I was astonished in
the first test the number of people
that had no calculator,
or the calculator was not working
and so on. We have a few,
but this is a large class. I don't
have enough calculators for
everybody. Don't grade the test.
If you feel you are not doing as
well as you'd like, don't give up.
You just leave the grading to us.
And, you are not competing with
your classmates.
50 is a pass. Everybody can pass.
There's no success coming at the
expense of the classmate.
And, as always, do your own work.
You've got an aid sheet, you've got
your tables of constants,
you've got your periodic tables,
there's no reason to resort to any
kind of intellectual dishonesty.
And, our goal is to have them back
to you on Thursday in recitation.
So, good luck. I want you just to
show me what you know.
And, I think it's appropriate that
we don't have a weekly test tomorrow.
So, I know there's a lot of
disappointment when I say this,
but there will be no weekly test.
We'll catch up afterwards. OK, so
last day we looked at the selection
rules for reflection in cubic
crystals and saw that we could
identify, distinguish different
crystals from one another on the
basis of the patterns
in the line spectrum.
Towards the end we talked about
symmetry. And I think I gave you
the page here on the lab book of
Danny Schechtman when he first
started to see that he's got
fivefold symmetry.
And, so the music at the beginning
I was playing,
Take Five by Dave Brubeck,
I was looking for songs in 5/4 time.
So, I had this one as well.
Remember this one? [MUSIC PLAYS]
Count it: one,
two, three, four,
five, one, two, three,
four, five. But then they wimp out
and they go to 4/4 here.
Now it's a disco song. I guess
they feel that people can't dance to
5/4 time, and it had to be danceable
or else it wouldn't be marketable.
But that's 5/4, very strange time.
OK, today we're going to move on to
our discussion of solids,
ordered solids. Up until now,
I've been treating crystals as
though they're perfect.
though they're perfect in two ways,
perfect crystals in terms of
chemical composition,
perfection in terms of chemical
composition.
And that's to say that we're looking
at pure materials,
and also perfection in terms of
atomic arrangement.
And so, that means we are treating
them as though they are defect free.
Two types of perfection: see, we
are talking about chemical
composition and we are talking about
atomic arrangement.
Both are critical in determining
the performance of material.
But, real engineering materials are
not perfect. They contain
impurities. And,
we've seen that there are desirable
in impurities such as dopants,
and there are undesirable impurities
such as contaminants.
And, part of what were doing in the
last unit was studying how to manage
impurities in such a way as to get
desirable properties.
Well, the same thing happens with
defects. In some cases,
we have atoms not always found at
their lattice points.
Atoms sometimes misbehave.
They don't go where they're told.
And that can lead to consequences,
mechanical failure. But, if we are
clever about it,
if we learn how to manage defects,
we can engineer performance that is
minimally damaging.
And, in some cases,
we can enhance the performance of a
material. So,
we are going to get tailored
properties through defect
engineering.
So, that's what I want to introduce
today. So, we're going to go to the
handout because this is a lot of
taxonomy here,
and sort of definitions.
So I thought we could just read
along together.
So, the defects are classified on
the basis of dimensionality.
So we're going to look at zero
dimensional point defects.
Then we will go to one-dimensional
line, two dimensional interfacial,
and three dimensional bulk defects.
So, the first thing is point
defects, start at zero dimension.
And, these are localized
disruptions in the regularity
of the lattice.
How local at the level of one
lattice site, at the level of one
lattice site. And,
so there's three types we're going
to look at. The first one is the
substitutional impurity.
And, if you flip over on the
backside, I've copied this cartoon.
And so, here's a substitutional
impurity atom.
We've seen this already when we put
phosphorus into silicon.
One example: it occupies a normal
lattice site. So,
there is the dopant that we've seen
before. And, I'll show you towards
the end of the lecture,
boron in diamond.
Substitutional,
it actually sits at the normal
carbon lattice site.
They are also alloying elements
such as magnesium in aluminum.
There are very few metals that are
used in commerce in pure form.
Most metals are used in the form of
alloys, that is to say solid
solutions. So,
for example, this aluminum can is
dominantly aluminum and contains a
certain amount of magnesium and a
certain amount of silicon.
And, this is designed to give it
the properties it needs.
One of the main properties that we
need in this can stock is the
ability to have very,
very rapid glide of the atoms.
If you look very carefully, there's
no seam on the bottom of this can.
This is made out of a single sheet
of aluminum. And so,
the sheet moves over a dye,
press punches down, up, down,
and forms the U-shaped right
circular cylinder,
and then a second piece is crimped
onto the top.
You can imagine the high speed at
which the atoms are gliding over one
another, and part of what gives us
the ability to deform is the
alloying. So,
magnesium is purposely added to
aluminum. We have seen colored
golds. And, one example is nickel
going into gold,
which will turn it from its very
buttery, almost buttery ductility
into something that's got a little
bit of strength to it.
I mean, you don't want a ring that
if you put it down on the dresser it
starts to deform.
So, we have to give it some strength.
And, in this case,
we can alter its color.
So, this is nickel atom sitting on
the FCC site normally occupied by
gold, again, a substitutional
impurity. And,
here's the last one.
We learned about 7-Up,
and the lithium citrate in 7-Up,
suppose you're on call and you're
administering saline in the hospital,
and it's supposed to be 5% sodium
chloride in water.
But if there's a lithium impurity
substituting for sodium in the
sodium chloride lattice,
it's going to dissolve.
And if you've got some sodium
deficient patient and you give them
some lithium chloride,
it's going to be a bad day at the
office. So, substitutional
impurities can have deleterious
effects. So, those are examples of
substitutional impurities.
The second type is the interstitial
impurity. And,
it occupies the position between the
lattice sites.
And, if you go to the cartoon,
you'll see this highlighted. And,
the interstitial impurity, obviously
this atom is small.
It has to fit into the void space
between the atoms.
So, we did the calculations.
We know that a close packed FCC
lattice is 74% matter,
and 26% void. Well, that 26% void
is not just randomly distributed.
It is the nothing in between the
atoms. So, I could take all the
atoms away, and I could give you a
lattice comprising the
interstitial sites.
You understand the concept.
A lattice is simply points in space.
So, instead of putting gold atoms
there, let's put the space between
the gold atoms.
And, imagine what we can do.
So, here's an example of an
interstitial atom.
It's small, and it's obviously an
impurity because it's different from
the composition of the parent
material. And,
so, there are desirable and
undesirable. So,
an example of a desirable element is
carbon in iron.
Carbon in iron is the basis for
steel.
Without carbon and iron,
we wouldn't have steel. And,
the interesting thing about carbon
in iron is that the radius of the
carbon atom is actually greater than
the radius of the interstitial site
in iron, greater than the radius of
the interstitial site in iron.
So, therefore, when the carbon goes
into that interstitial site,
it actually distorts the lattice.
It presses back on the parent iron
lattice. And,
through this distortion,
strengthens the material.
Another example is hydrogen in
lanthanum nickel five.
It goes into the interstices in
this compound.
Lanthanum nickel five has voids
that are large enough to accommodate
hydrogen. And,
hydrogen can go in this,
acts as a sponge, and hydrogen at
peak loading can go
in at this level.
We have a huge amount of hydrogen
going in here.
The density of hydrogen in
lanthanum nickel five at saturation
is greater than liquid hydrogen
itself. And, this material is under
investigation along with others like
it in the context of hydrogen
powered vehicles.
If we're going to put hydrogen in
cars, if at some point fuel cells
become practical,
what is going to be the mode of
storing hydrogen?
Do we want compressed hydrogen?
We're going to have to have all
sorts of protection in
case of a collision.
Well, this might be a safer way of
putting hydrogen in the vehicle.
So, interstitial packing is
advantageous in this case.
But, if we get our wires crossed,
and instead of putting hydrogen in
lanthanum nickel five,
we put hydrogen in iron,
that leads to deleterious effects.
Hydrogen in iron embrittles iron.
And it loses its ductility,
becomes very brittle, and can fail
prematurely. And this is also
germane to the hydrogen economy.
In this country, we can deliver
energy through the electric grid,
and we can deliver gas through gas
pipelines.
You cannot send hydrogen through the
gas pipelines because the gas
pipelines are stable with
hydrocarbon contents,
but not stable with hydrogen.
Hydrogen under pressure will
embrittle those pipelines.
That means that we would have to
build a new infrastructure to pipe
hydrogen over long distances.
And, that infrastructure cannot be
made out of steel because steel will
be embrittled. It's not
going to be cheap.
These are cost issues.
You need to know this because
people are going to ask you.
You're from MIT. They're going to
ask you help make policy.
You can't just get on board and say,
well, we'll fix it somehow.
Hydrogen is very small. It goes
places where it's not supposed to be.
OK, then the third type of defect
is called the vacancy.
And that's simply an unoccupied
lattice site different from the
interstitial. It's a site that's
not occupied. And so,
here's the cartoon. You see this is
a regular atom that hasn't been
placed on its proper site.
And, we have a vacancy in that
location. And so,
there's two types of vacancy
formations. The first is when the
material is being solidified,
whether it's solidifying from the
liquid, whether it's vapor
deposition, or whether it's a
solid-solid transformation.
So, in some instances, all of the
sites don't get filled.
And that there's an extreme case,
such as the wall of a nuclear
reactor vessel where under high
bombardment of neutron flux,
over time, atoms are literally
dislodged from their
lattice positions.
And, you put this on a regular
maintenance schedule because you can
imagine over a certain period of
time the material starts to look,
at the atomic level, more nearly
like Swiss cheese.
And so, that's not good.
So, vacancies are present.
And, they're always going to be
present.
Tom, do you think we could switch
the video over to the document
camera, please?
OK, what I've got here is,
well, actually it's an object of art.
This was made by an artiste in
Montréal back in the 1960s.
And, all it is, is two pieces of
poly methyl methacrylate that have
been milled and joined.
And, in between here are 2,
00 ball bearings.
So, we just have 2000 ball bearings,
and I'm going to try illuminating
from the bottom,
see that make things better.
Much better. And now, if I learned
how to focus, OK,
good, and now we're going to zoom.
OK, so now, what do you see? You
see atoms packing.
These are hard spheres.
And, they're packing in ways that
indicate the way atoms would pack.
You see, here's regular crystal
arrays. Here's some disorder.
Oh, this is even the gas phase.
Look at this, see, we have
everything. OK,
so now, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to anneal.
So, I'm going to lift this up.
And, annealing would be the
equivalent of tapping this.
OK, I'm giving thermal energy to
this because thermal energy causes
atom motion. Look at the impact.
I have annealed out so much of the
defects.
And now, look at large,
regular regions. There's a surface.
I see a few gas atoms up there.
And, look, vacancies.
There will always be vacancies
above zero Kelvin.
You can come to my office anytime
you want. I defy,
I challenge anyone to anneal all of
the vacancies out.
There will always be a few
vacancies in here.
And, sometimes vacancies coalesce.
There is a divacancy.
There's another divacancy.
This is a good day for divacancies.
The Red Sox win the World Series.
A lot of unusual things are
happening here.
OK, so let's take a look.
There is an expression for the
vacancy population in any crystal.
So, what I'm showing you, this is
what's going on in steel.
This is what's going on in that
aluminum beverage container.
This is what's going on in the
airplane wings that you look out
over when you fly: vacancies.
OK, so what's the population of
vacancies? And,
the calculation of vacancy
population involves what I'm going
to give as equilibrium,
meaning it's in equilibrium with the
surroundings in terms of temperature.
It's at thermal equilibrium,
equilibrium population of vacancies.
And, this is in a crystal.
And so, what we're going to do is
it's a comparison of the binding
energy, comparison of the binding
energy to the energy of disruption
because you can imagine the binding
energy of an atom is the negative of
the energy to form a vacancy.
How you form a vacancy? You can
imagine, you go in with atomic
tweezers and you pull an atom out.
And, what bonds do you have to
break? The bonds that bonded
that atom to others.
So, this is minus the energy of
vacancy formation.
And, the disruptive energy is,
in our case, a thermal energy. And,
so, there's a way of expressing this.
And, we're going to say,
it's given by the following.
We're going to compare these two in
an exponential not unlike the one
you saw earlier in the course.
So, I'm going to define the
fraction of sites that are
unoccupied, which will be the ratio
of the number of vacancies per unit
volume to the number of
sites per unit volume.
So, the nv is number of vacancies
per unit volume,
and big N is the number of atomic
sites, number of atomic
sites per unit volume.
OK, and that's going to be given by
the ratio mediated through this
exponential of the energy.
And, I loosely move energy and
enthalpy back-and-forth.
This is the enthalpy of vacancy
formation energy over
the thermal energy.
And, how do we get a rough measure
of the thermal energy?
Product of the Boltzmann constant
and absolute temperature.
So, what are we doing? We are
taking this onto the temperature
distribution, and we are saying,
where is this required energy in
relation to the average energy of
the system, and in particular,
the high end tail. So, and then,
it has a pre-factor, A, and A is
just an entropic pre-factor.
And, it's not equal to one.
A will take values between a tenth
up to about ten.
It's typically on the order of,
oh, four, five, something like this,
but in some cases it can even be
less than one.
So, this is a relationship that
tells us what the fraction of
unoccupied sites is as a
function of temperature.
So, we could go in and calculate
what the effective bond energy is
because we know what the thermal
energy is. So,
we could work backwards and
calculate that.
So, I did a sample calculation.
I was wondering, what should be the
vacancy population in,
say, a piece of copper?
So, I said, all right, copper,
it happens that the enthalpy of
formation of a vacancy is 1.
9 electron volts per atom.
And, the pre-factor is equal to 4.
. I had to look this up in tables.
This is not from first principles
calculation. So,
I said, OK, let's look at room
temperature. At room temperature,
I plugged these numbers in and I got
the fraction of vacant sites as ten
to the minus 21.
Well, if you multiply by the
density of copper,
that turns out to be 85 vacancies
per cubic centimeter.
I mean, this is vanishingly small.
This is almost the inverse. This
is almost none,
right, because we have roughly
Avogadro's number of atoms per cubic
centimeter for condensed matter.
So, this is really, really low, ten
to the 21, ten to the 23.
There's 100 difference, and sure
enough, there it is,
85. There's so few you could give
each of them a name.
And then, so then I said,
well, what happens if we go to the
melting point, at the melting
point of copper?
OK, I'm not going to melt copper.
It's like ice at 0¡ C. It's copper
at the threshold of melting but
still solid. If you do the
calculations at the melting point of
copper, you get 7.
5 times ten to the minus five,
which now turns out to be about 70
parts per million on an atom basis.
So, for every million copper sites,
you can expect about 70 of them to
be unoccupied.
So, now we are starting to get up
to real numbers because that would
give us a vacancy population of six
times ten to the 18th
per cubic centimeter.
That's substantial.
This is the kind of stuff that
would be perceptible if this were a
dopant. If this were a dopant
concentration,
this would alter the electrical
properties of silicon.
And, here's the way to look at this.
What's going on here?
What's going on is this critical
ratio, this is so important.
The ratio of the binding energy to
the thermal energy,
at room temperature,
this ratio is about 50 to one.
It's about 50 to one.
At the melting point,
it's about 10 to one. And,
that's what's going on. You are
shifting the distribution way over,
and giving yourself the ability to
rip the copper atoms out of their
sites. So, that's interesting
to know.
OK, Tom, may we go back to the
computer please for graphics?
Thank you. OK, so now, I want to
talk about point defects in ionic
crystals because there's a special
twist here. With an ionic crystal,
if you've got sodium chloride, you
can't just remove a sodium ion
because you violate charge
neutrality. So,
when you make vacancies in an ionic
crystal, you have to take them out.
You have to make those vacancies by
removing atoms in neutral units.
So, let's look at the various types.
The first one is called Schottky
imperfection. And,
it's the formation of equivalent,
not equal, but "equi-valent" numbers
of cationic and anionic vacancies.
And, there's the other cartoon on
the backside of the handout.
So, here's the Schottky
imperfection where you see - the
video graphic is not so good.
If you squint just a little bit,
you'll see, this is not just an
array of dark spheres,
but there are light spheres in
between the dark spheres.
And, the light spheres represent the
anions, and the dark spheres
represent the cations.
And, what you are seeing here is
the pair. We are missing both the
anion here in the midst of four
cations, and the cation over here,
in order to preserve charge
neutrality. Now,
they don't necessarily have to be
side by each. I mean,
the cation vacancy can be way over
here, and anion vacancy could be way
over here. But globally,
it's the same number.
And, so let's look at how that works.
One way to describe that is to
think about, instead of removing the
cation and anion,
the other way to think about this
mathematically is to say,
suppose I take, here's nothing.
I'm going to take some nothing.
But, it's not any old nothing.
It's FCC nothing.
And, I'm going to dissolve the FCC
nothing into sodium chloride.
So, let's do that.
You'll get the idea.
Conceptually, it's so cool.
So, how do I make, I want to make a
sodium chloride vacancy pair.
So, what I do is, instead of
ripping out a sodium,
and ripping out a chloride,
what I do is I take nothing,
which I represent as null, and I
dissolve it. So,
I'm going to take nothing,
but I'm going to have some nothing
that goes to the cationic site,
and nothing that goes to the anionic
site. So, this is V,
is a vacancy on a sodium site,
and a vacancy on a chloride site.
So, this is charge neutral now.
OK, we said, well, it's only
nothing anyways.
Well, let's think about it.
If you look at sodium vacancy,
sodium vacancy is charge zero, but
it's on a cationic sub lattice.
It's zero, but everywhere around it,
it's got neighbors of comparable
charge, except this is in a land of
plus one for V sodium.
So, if this means it has an apparent,
I'm going to put quotation marks
here, it has an apparent charge of
minus one. Zero in a land of plus
one is relatively negative.
And, what about the chloride?
The chloride vacancy is zero in a
land of minus one.
So, a zero in a land of minus one
is effectively a plus one.
So, let's put that down.
So, this is, I want to put here,
this indicates that this is locally
minus, and this indicates it's
locally plus. The way I remember
these is, this slash reminds me of a
minus sign. And,
the plus is sort of like the
crosshairs of the plus sign.
That's how I remember it.
OK, and we can do the same as we did
for the vacancy fraction,
and compute a Schottky fraction.
What's the fraction of Schottky
defects? It's going to be the
number of Schottky defects divided
by the total number of sites.
And, it'll be an equation of this
form, some pre-exponential times the
exponential of the ratio of the
energy to form the Schottky defect
divided by the product of the
Boltzmann constant and temperature.
And, for sodium chloride,
the Schottky energy is on the order
of about 2.5 electron volts.
And, that's about double what it is
for copper. So,
and that makes sense.
It should take more energy to make
a vacancy pair than it does to make
a vacancy. And,
Coulombic forces of attraction in
ionic crystals are more intense than
metallic bonding forces in metal
crystals. I want to show you one
other one. This is what's going on
in the oxygen sensor of your
car. It's zirconia.
And, I'm going to show you later how
you manage the defects in zirconia
to advantage. So,
how do I make a vacancy in zirconia?
The dominant vacancy is Schottky.
And, I'm going to write again null.
I'm going to dissolve nothing into
zirconia. So,
going to make a zirconium vacancy
and two oxygen vacancies.
I have to preserve the
stoichiometry of nothing.
Nothing counts here,
OK, because what's the local charge?
This is zero in a land of plus four.
So, it's apparently minus four.
And, every oxygen is a zero in a
land of minus two.
All of the oxide ions are minus two.
This oxide ion vacancy is zero.
Zero in a land of minus two is plus
two, apparently.
So, I have minus four apparent,
two times minus two apparent, charge
neutrality, and this is now
equivalent numbers of cation
and anion vacancies.
Very cool. OK,
so there's another way,
though. There's another way to make
vacancies, and that's called the
Frenkel imperfection.
And, it's the formation of an ion
vacancy and ion interstitial.
So, that's shown over here where a
little cation, you see the cation?
See this cation's gone over to
another cation.
There's an interstitial in here.
You see the little cation? Cation
left and went over here?
But see, it didn't leave.
It didn't leave the crystal.
It moved to another place in the
crystal. So, I don't have to worry
about compensating with the ion of
opposite charge because the total
cation population hasn't changed.
But, I have created a cation vacancy.
So, this is what the issue is here.
And so, with Frenkel, clearly with
Frenkel, Frenkel occurs in crystals
where you have wide variations in
the radii. So,
for Frenkel, the condition is that
the radius of the cation must be
either substantially larger than the
radius of anion or it must be
substantially smaller than the
radius of the anion.
If you have ions that are roughly
nearly equal in dimension,
the interstitial site isn't big
enough to take the ion.
So, let's look at that one.
A good example of this is silver
bromide. Silver bromide forms
Frenkels because,
as you know, bromine is big.
Bromide is huge, and silver is
small. And when it loses an
electron, it's smaller.
So, I've got a small cation,
and a honking big anion. And so,
there's lots of room in there.
And, here's the way we'd write that:
silver sitting on a silver site now
wants to move.
And see, it's neutral because
silver is plus one in a land of plus
one. So, I can even put a little x
there to show that it's neutral.
So, silver on a silver site now
becomes silver on an interstitial
site. And, an interstitial site is
zero. And, silver is plus one.
So, now, it's apparently plus one.
And, what's going to do to charge
compensate? It's going to leave
behind a vacancy.
Obviously, it jumped off this site.
So, there is a vacancy. And that
vacancy is what?
The vacancy is zero in a land of
plus one. So,
zero in a land of plus one is
apparently minus.
This thing makes sense.
It's consistent. And, likewise,
we can write a formula for the
fraction of Frenkel
sites in a crystal.
It would be the number of Frenkels
divided by the total number of
atomic sites for that,
which then will equal A times some
exponential expression of the ratio
of the formation energy for the
Frenkel defect divided by the
product of the Boltzmann constant
and temperature.
And, the Frenkel energy,
what do you think? It's going to be
closer to that of the Schottky
energy, or closer to that of the
single atom vacancy?
It's about one electron volt.
It's closer to that of the single
atom. And, it's typically the
cations. It's typically the cations
because normally the anions are the
big ones. Fluoride is the one
exception, OK?
But generally,
it's the cations that are going to
go interstitially.
The last one is the F center.
The F center, they don't talk about
in your books,
but it's a really cool one.
I like this one. The F center
occurs in non-stoichiometry.
It may surprise you,
but it's possibly to have sodium
chloride that isn't 1:1 sodium and
chlorine. It's possible to have
something that is chlorine deficient.
So, let's see,
what would happen if we were to
dissolve excess sodium?
I'm going to dissolve excess sodium
into sodium chloride.
Well, I can't dissolve a neutral.
Sodium chloride will not accept a
neutral. So, what's the only way I
can make sodium soluble in sodium
chloride? I have to convert it into
sodium ion. So,
I'm going to make a sodium ion.
And, I'm going to be left with an
electron. What am I going to do
with that electron?
Where is that electron going to go?
Think. You've got valence bands
that are filled.
Do you see a parallel between this
and putting phosphorus into silicon?
You've got this extra electron.
This thing has bonding capability.
This is a fifth wheel, didn't know
what to do. So,
one way to model this is I'm going
to now to give you the full notation
as to put sodium on a sodium site.
So, now this is sodium plus. I've
got an electron,
and what? I have to make a vacancy
on a chloride site in order to
compensate for this excess electron.
And now, let's look at the way this
thing is going to operate.
I've got sodium ions in some FCC
lattice. Here's a chloride vacancy
that's been created to compensate
here. So, this is VCl.
And, where is this electron going
to be? Its electron is not attached
to any one of these sodiums.
Do you know of another example
where you ended up with something
that was apparently positive and
motionless in a crystal with an
extra electron that was attracted by
Coulombic forces?
If you had to model this operation,
what model might you choose? You
could use a modified Bohr model to
model the electron motion around the
vacancy in an F center.
Yeah, this is really cool.
This is really cool. It's called f
center because it comes from the
German farbe, which means color.
These form color centers because if
you go through the Bohr model,
the energy levels in here are in the
visible. And so,
the different crystals we can
identify, if you take sodium
chloride, lithium chloride,
potassium chloride, they're all
white salts. But,
if we create vacancies by injecting
energy, say in the form of an
electrical shock,
we will dope the crystal different
colors. And the colors change with
the identity of the crystal because
the energies are going
to be different.
OK, good, so that's the end of point
defects. Now,
let's look at line defects.
Line defects are very important
because they answer this question.
Data made line defects necessary.
People in the early part of the 20th
century were trying to figure out
what the ultimate yield
strength of a metal is.
So, let's take a look at,
say, two planes of atoms. And,
I'm just going to, for simplicity,
connect these with little struts to
indicate that there's some bonding
going on here.
And, I want to ask the question,
what is the shear strength, the
magnitude of the shear strength
necessary because these two planes
to slide over one another?
This is going to be involved in the
yield of a crystal.
Well, one way of doing this
calculation is to say,
let's look at, say, bond strength
between pairs of atoms.
So, look at pair bond strength
times the bond density,
right? If we take pair strength
times bond density,
that should give us some round
number that would be representative
of how much energy it takes for us
to be able to shear the material.
And, this quantity that we're
looking for is the yield strength,
denoted sigma sub y. And what we
find is that the measured value of
the yield strength is on the order
of only about 1/10 of the yield
strength as determined by theory.
Something is way wrong.
Well, this was solved by Orowan.
Orowan was a professor in Budapest
in the 1930s. After World War II,
he ended up here at MIT and he
finished his career in the
mechanical engineering department.
He was a brilliant theoretician in
the area of strength of metals,
failure in metals. So, the story
goes, this is the apocryphal story,
is that Orowan came home one day
from the university and went
up to his apartment.
And there was a long hallway and a
runner, a carpet,
a long carpet, along the hallway.
And the chambermaid was just
finishing cleaning,
and she was going to put the carpet
back. She had moved it out of the
way, and she was going to move it
back. And so,
he came up and offered to help her
move the carpet.
And she told him to get out of the
way. And instead,
what she did is rather then drag the
carpet in order to displace it,
what she did is she went to the far
end of the carpet and
made a little kink.
Made a little kink in the carpet,
stamped her foot, and propagated the
kink all the way down.
And then: made a second kink,
stamped her foot, and propagated the
carpet all the way down.
So, what's the difference?
What's the difference? Well,
with Orowan, if we stand at this end
and pull, we've got the coefficient
of friction along the entire length
of the carpet.
It takes a huge amount of energy.
If, instead, we invest a little bit
of energy to make the kink,
and then propagate the kink,
we can move the carpet in these
small amounts.
So, what we've done is now all we
have to come up with is the amount
of energy to lift off that little
patch of carpet.
And it will propagate very easily.
He looked at this and he said, that
could explain what's going on here.
So, I've got a little cartoon that
shows, actually it's showing the
caterpillar moving here.
But, can you imagine if this is the
plane of atoms such that there is an
extra plane sandwiched
in here that ends?
And now, if I want to shear the top
three rows of atoms versus the
bottom three rows,
instead of having to break every one
of these bonds,
I have to break them all.
Look at here. All I do is I break
this one, and then I break this one.
And then I break this one, and then
I break this one.
And so what I do is I break one
bond and just keep propagating it.
And that's the dislocation. That's
the dislocation.
It's a line defect that involves the
misregistry of atoms.
And through this, it allows us the
ability to deform metals at values
substantially below those of the
entire crystalline,
makes sense now. So,
here's another cartoon showing the
same thing. And,
how do these dislocations move?
These dislocations move along
close-packed planes in close
packed directions.
Tom, may we go back to the document
camera, please?
OK, so here is,
I'm going to now go to top view,
top lamp. Look at this. This is
face centered cubic.
Where are the bonds going to be
strongest? This is going to be like
rafts of atoms moving.
Where are the bonds going to be
strongest? They're going to be
strongest in the plane
with the most bonds.
So, that's going to be the 1-1-1
plane because the 1-1-1,
if you look at this atom here,
you see the hexagon starting?
There's the hexagon.
Train your eye on this one.
One, two, three, four, and then
there will five,
six. So, this is a close-packed
plane. It's got six nearest
neighbors in the plane,
three above, and three below.
This is the 1-1-1 plane. It goes
up the diagonal,
OK? It goes up the diagonal.
So, this is the plane that has the
most bonds. If there are the most
bonds in the plane,
that's the plane that has the
greatest strength and will not give.
And, doesn't it go axiomatically
that if I have the most bonds in the
plane, then normal to the plane I'm
going to have weakest bonding?
So, we have these strong rafts of
1-1-1 planes that want to slide.
Now, within the plane, how does
something move?
This is like pushing the wet noodle
question. So,
if I'm in this 1-1-1 plane,
which direction am I going to move?
I'm going to move along the
direction where I have the greatest
strength, the greatest rigidity,
and that means along the direction
where I have the greatest number of
bonds. So, this is along the 1-1-1
direction, see,
excuse me, the 0-1-1 direction.
I'm in the red plane, and then this
is across the diagonal of the face.
So, I'm moving in the close packed
direction in the close packed plane
because that's where the
bonds are most dense.
So, Tom, may we go back to the
computer video please?
So, here's the set of directions.
I just showed you FCC. The highest
density plane is 1-1-1,
and the close packed direction,
that's the direction where the atoms
touch. You know this.
They touch along 0-1-1.
In BCC, it's the complement.
The highest density plane is the
cube diagonal that contains that
central atom. And,
the closest packed direction is the
body diagonal. That's
where the atoms touch.
Simple cubic it's the face and the
face. So, this is now the origin of
mechanical behavior.
This is the origin of mechanical
behavior. I can look at this and I
can tell you how the material will
deform. So, if I take the set of
close packed planes moving in close
packed directions.
Together, this represents the slip
system. And this is how the
material deforms.
And so, we'll come back to that
next day. I see we're getting close
to the end of the hour.
So, let me jump ahead here,
jump through this, we'll go through
that. I'll show you that another
time. All right,
I'll talk to you about defects and
crystals.
I talked to you about boron.
You know what happens if you dope
silicon with boron?
You end up with something that is a
p-type semiconductor.
It's shy one electron,
generates a hole. This is the Hope
Diamond. What makes the Hope
Diamond so precious is not only its
size, but it's blue.
And, how did it get to be blue?
It got to be blue by boron doping.
It's boron doping at around one part
per million. And what this does is
it puts an acceptor level about 0.
eV above the valence band.
And with the acceptor level about 0.
eV above the valence band, we now
have transitions that give us this
beautiful blue color.
So, what you're looking at is -
these are not Hope Diamonds.
This is just some 51 little units
by Cartier. And,
this is the rest. This is in the
Smithsonian. So,
if you're in Washington sometime and
you want to study boron doping,
well, you can go and see this at the
national gem collection.
And you can stand with your
contemporaries and explain to them
the boron doping and how it makes
the thing blue.
All right, good luck on Wednesday.